and ladies and gentlemen I try to bring
you the best
I try to bring you the best
amen Dr Joel Wall's work has resulted in
the publication of more than 70 peer
review and and and uh ref referred
Journal articles in the fields of
nutrition and pharmaceutical research he
promotes worldwide health Beauty and
Youthful energy and for more than 40
years it has been Dr Wall's mission to
bring bring accurate and timely health
information to the world ladies and
gentlemen I want you to stand to your
feet and welcome our speaker for the
next couple of nights as he takes us on
a journey to achieving the health that
we want please welcome Dr Joel wallik as
he comes at this time oh thank you
Pastor dollar and Pastor Taffy and his
whole crew they've been so
wonderful high blood pressure is not
genetic and so I want everybody on the
count of three to yell Hallelujah want 2
three
hallelujah it's not
genetic which means you can control it
you don't need permission from anybody
you can control it just by supplementing
with the mighty
90 that's
it you learn how to take your own blood
pressure and it slowly goes away over a
period of a month or two I've had people
who were on blood pressure medication
for 40 45 years and in two weeks time
they don't have high blood pressure
anymore they go back to a normal life
men get sexier
they don't have that you know Low T and
Ed and all them initial things high
blood pressure is not genetic high blood
pressure is a simple mineral deficiency
disease that can afflict anybody simple
mineral deficien disase you supplement
with the minerals you don't get it if
you don't supplement with the minerals
you do get high blood pressure and if
you supplement with minerals it goes
away it's just that simple high blood
pressure
medication can lower blood pressure but
it doesn't solve the problem that caused
the high blood pressure you can
symptomatically reduce high blood
pressure but you're still going to die
from the complications of high blood
pressure even if though your blood
pressure is quote under control unquote
so once you appreciate that you're going
to add 25 to 50 healthful years to your
life now I love this this story this
fell here 88 years old and this is
published in the New England Journal of
Medicine one of the most prestigious
medical journals this old dude 88 years
old he eats 20 25 eggs a
day now why would this old dude in in
1991 be eating 25 eggs a day well the
reason is you have to ask yourself I
mean maybe he ate 25 eggs a day because
he didn't have any teeth and couldn't
eat steaks
anymore or maybe he owned an egg Ranch
and you know was quality checking his
product but the reality is when when you
read that scientific article the more
eggs he ate the the he realized he
became more
studly he became more
studly the more eggs he
ate because
testosterone is 95% by weight
cholesterol so when you go on a
cholesterol restricted diet and you go
from cream and butter and eggs and large
to margarine and cooking oils and you
take drugs to lower your
cholesterol there's nobody
home so
ladies if you want your man to be
studly 6 to 10 eggs a
day now they cannot be
fried they can be soft poached they can
be soft boiled they can be soft
scrambling butter not margarine or
Oils now I can tell you from personal
experience I'm 71 years old and 10 eggs
a day
works
who see now the ladies gentlemen the
ladies understand what I'm talking
about okay next
slide